Este es el sepelio de un niño de 14 años
en Jerusalén y este otro de una pareja
pocos kilómetros de distancia en berge
mesh son tres de las siete víctimas
causadas por el palestino de 21 años que
abrió fuego el viernes en la noche
frente a una sinagoga en el asentamiento
de nieve Jacob en Jerusalén este antes
de ser abatido la casa de la familia del
atacante fue intervenida por el ejército
israelí que difundió las imágenes el
inmueble será destruido un castigo
colectivo que se ha vuelto habitual en
Israel cuyo gobierno de extrema derecha
acaba de ampliar su abanico represivo
hemos decidido suprimir los derechos de
seguridad social de las familias que
apoyan el terrorismo
y debatiríamos otras medidas como la
supresión del documento de identidad y
residencia de la familia de terroristas
al mismo tiempo hemos acelerado y
ampliado el permiso para aportar armas a
miles de Israel
esta escalada se produce tras un primer
ataque el viernes y un segundo el sábado
cuando un de 13 años hirió a dos
personas en chiloán anteriormente una
redada israelí había matado a nueve
personas el jueves en yenín este
contexto ha reavivado las tensiones
entre colonos israelíes y palestinos
cerca de ramala este hombre constata los
daños su vehículo fue destruido y su
casa está parcialmente quemada acusa a
los colonos israelíes de ser los
responsables directos de la destrucción
no pasó un mes sin que haya una pelea
entre los dos bandos ya sea por la
destrucción de Olivos o cuando nos
impiden arar la tierra contractores
quitándonos por la fuerza estamos en
conflicto con ellos y no ha empezado hoy
guardias de seguridad de israelíes
causaron la muerte de un palestino de 18
años luego un tiroteo el domingo cerca
de un asentamiento en cisjordania
ocupada
Anthony blinken secretario de estado de
Estados Unidos está en Israel en donde
se reunirá con etallao y luego en ramala
para encontrarse con majuda Baz
presidente de la autoridad Palestina la
misión casi imposible de blinken es
rebajar la